okay that should be it
hello everybody I'm making this video
not today later today at 12 30. today
we're here for the second day of NDC
hope you had the first fantastic day we
had to talk about controllers and
minimal apis and this talk is as much
about controllers as much as it is about
minimal apis and also what they mean for
the future of.net in general
so just a quick intro I'm Nick Heim I'm
a bunch of stuff if you know me you
probably know me from YouTube actually
how many of you know me from YouTube
that's a good amount there okay for the
rest of you you have to go and subscribe
that's a requirement for this talk
um I'm also turning 30 in April so I
thought it's a great idea to start my
own podcast which seems to be also a
legal requirement so if you want to see
some interesting podcasts with some
amazing talks
um or discussions with people like
Damien Edwards mods for the future
of.net and C sharp I highly recommend
you go ahead and check that out
um and also just a quick plug if you
like topics like minimal apis testing or
dependency injection or other things
that can really take your skills to the
next level then I have my own courses at
nickjazza.com I highly recommend you
check that out now there's a show of
hands has any of you seen this talk
already from NBC London last year
the hell are you doing here
like I mean it hasn't really changed
that much but um thank you for being
here
now how many of you know what minimal
apis are
you see
okay that's a good number that's way
better than last time and how many of
you have them in production
that's really good
and if the remaining people who actually
know who they are who who do you think
or just raise your hand how many of you
would never use them in production or
think will never use them in production
don't be afraid this is a safe space
I saw you
okay so fun fact minimal apis are
actually the most loved feature of the
dotnet6 release by far I mean when they
came out everybody just instantly loved
them it was amazing to see the community
just come together on Twitter and really
Embrace and hug this awesome feature
that really removes that barrier to
entry of making a new API with tons of
controllers and the startup.cs and
program.cs and making it extremely easy
obviously this is a very long-winded
joke people hated it
um and some of them really still do they
think it is not for them and they think
that the asp.net core team is actually
wasting their time doing all this
now let's see if that is true by the end
of this talk
but you might be for those of you who
did not raise your hands what are
minimal apis Nick well I could have a
very fancy quote and just explain what
it is but really there is nothing that
describes the minimal apis are better
than this
this is fundamentally what minimal apis
are these four lines of code are a valid
API you can take right now and run
ingot.net
six and Beyond code base and it will
work there's a bit of a lie on this
quote there's actually a CS prods
required for this to run because you
need to specify that this is a.net
project but as long as you have that
there you can do dotted run and we run
you're going to have a single hello
world endpoint
now for those of you who haven't touched
C sharp in a long time you might be like
okay how is that even possible we're
gonna see that but before we see that I
want to talk about the five fundamental
points you have in here so the first
thing we have is this Builder the
Builder is responsible for configuration
logging Service registration for Di and
all that
then between the Builder and the next
line is where you would have your log
providers being added Your Service
registration all that goes there and
then you materialize that configuration
or that definition into a web
application which is this new
abstraction of what is a web app in.net
the gaming.net6
and then it's your time to shine it is
your time to add your end points no more
controllers no nothing you just say map
get map post map whatever and then you
can return a delegate you can return an
object enter whatever you want and that
will be serialized and return to your
browser the last thing is just running
the application that is it
but many of you who have worked with
other Technologies and other languages
as well might be thinking wait damn
minute that thing over here
that looks a whole lot like that thing
over there now I don't know if you can
see it but those are not both C sharp
the bottom thing is express.js from the
JavaScript world so Microsoft was that's
blatantly ripped up sorry my my lawyer
they get inspired by express.js heavily
to go ahead and make the same thing and
there's a reason express.js has seen
more use in web applications than
anything MVC or ASP network has done in
the past 10 years don't quote me on that
by the way
but
clearly there was a need for that
because why is Jas so popular if it's
such a bad language but it is so widely
used well it is because the barrier to
entry is just so so low
so
what if or sorry this is not actually A
New Concept at all python for example
with fast API it's the same idea all you
do is you import fast API you create
your app which you can imagine as the
same web application Factory and then
you define that endpoint you define what
you return and that is serialized as a
Json object
simple as that go with more cool
language and modern language does the
exact same thing with a project called
gen
so Jin has this idea of a gene.default
which is the same thing as well
application Factory then you can do Jane
dot get and you can Define your delegate
you have your gen context which is the
same as a HTTP context and then you
write a string you write Json you write
whatever you want back then you run it
even Nancy effects we have this in C
sharp how many of you remember Nancy FX
yeah that was good old days so Nancy
effects was this thing in asp.net where
you could just have a module and in that
module you can define an array of get
post put whatever you want and then your
endpoints and then have this delegate
that returns hello world and in this
case that would just return that which
at the time it was unheard of now again
it wasn't new because Nancy in itself
was actually copying Sinatra which was a
Ruby on Rails framework that was very
very popular and even here you can see
that exact same Simplicity requests
inatra get them the route do and then
end and that is it
now when I go back to what we saw before
with c-sharp because if you stop writing
C sharp in.net framework or C sharp
seven points two or whichever one is the
last version and you're probably like
how is that even possible well I made a
bit of an animation to show you how it's
possible and it took me three hours to
make so I appreciate it so all of these
features are flying and coming together
all of this were added in C sharp 9 10
and Dot net six
and that's how we get it and just
because I spent so much time for just
well
five ten seconds we're gonna see it
again just appreciate it
it's good it's you can tell how
it has a watermark
like I don't want people to steal it
like that guy made it
anyway
so let's talk about each one of those
features individually so we have top
level statements
now top level segments are actually a C
sharp nine feature not even a C sharp 10
which is the one that was paired with
a.net 6 release
and basically what happened is a.net
team took a step back and said you know
what
that looks stupid because it's the same
every single time you always have well
the name space is optional but you
always have a program class you always
have a static void or static int
mainstream array args I know it sounds
stupid there's more stupid to write it
every time and we have three levels of
nesting just to get started which is
just obnoxious so what happened in C
sharp 9 is top level statements were
introduced where now you just have the
using statement and then you say
console.writeline and you have the text
that you want the rest of it is implied
it is still there the code that you
eventually compile is that same
program.cs but you don't have to have it
there because it's supposed to be there
by default and it's what causes tons of
confusion in my comment section when
people who don't do C sharp see me write
something like this and like what is
this scripting it's like no it's C sharp
it's good
Okay C sharp has changed I'm gonna give
it a go
which is fundamental to this whole
effort for Simplicity
now some of you might say hey Nick you
could make it even simpler by just
removing the using and saying
system.console.writeline I'm just
matching it into one line and be like
we're cool you can have a right um you
can have a Hello World with just one
line of code
however that would sort of kill this
awesome Segway to the next feature
implicit using statements which is this
idea that hey there's like eight using
statements eight in spaces that we're
adding in every single one of our files
or most of the files and those are
things like link system.task system
itself is many of them
so now what you can do in C sharp 10 is
you can specify the implicit usings as
enable which is now is the default
actually and this will remove the need
for the using system to be there and a
bunch of others because behind the
scenes.net will do that for you and how
will it do it well with a new feature
called Global using statements so Global
using statements is this thing where you
can have a single CS project CS file and
drop a global using Global and something
and this will be globally added in every
single one of your files and really what
happens when you do enable on implicit
usings is a source generator kicks in
and says oh you don't have one of these
I'm going to go ahead and drop it and if
you say disabled you've just deletes it
if it's there and now all of these is
just implicitly added in every one of
your files removing the need for you to
have this using system in the case of
minimal apis
now another small feature that made this
possible is called inferred Lambda types
so previously in C sharp 9 even though
the compiler has all the information it
needs to know that this is a delegate
function that accepts a string and
returns a string if you went ahead and
you said VAR on the funk then it would
not compile it says I have no idea what
you're talking about I don't know what
this is so what C sharp 10 did is made
that possible and actually it was very
hard to do apparently I don't know why
but it was
and now the last small thing was
actually attributes on lambdas so you
could not have something like this
before.net6 to say like obsolete on the
Lambda function but because that.net
um asp.net core sorry team needed it
then now that is possible and this is
very indicative of the effort that went
on during the net six release and the C
sharp 10 release because the interesting
thing about it is that the c-sharp team
pushed the dotnet team and the dotnet
team pushed the c-sharp team because the
C sharp team had to make those changes
but net to do this the minimal API is to
exist and this will actually continue
with future releases and it's still
happening
now at this point
I want to go and take a look on a live
demo and I'm not using Azure so don't
worry this will work
and I'm gonna show you how minimal apis
really look like
so let me know
if you can see
this
all the way to the back
good good so I'm going to show you how
to create a minimal API from scratch and
I'm not going to cheat by using a
template I'm just going to make a
console application so I'm going to go
here in the getting started and say
in.net 7 in this case and say minimal
API
dot demo
and console I'm gonna go ahead and
create that
I'm going to delete all of that
and the only thing you need to do to
actually turn this into a web project is
actually go to the Cs project over here
and specifying the project SDK that this
is a microsoft.net DOT SDK dot many dot
web
that is it the moment I save you can see
something is happening in the background
it is just installing a bunch of
packages implicitly that you can't
really see here in the dependencies
so now I can go ahead and say VAR
Builder which is my first component so
web application
Dot createbuilder and at this point I
can actually pass down the arguments of
this project because they still
technically exist because it is wrapped
within that main method like we
mentioned before
then I'm going to create the app which
is Builder Dot
build
and then I'm going to run it
and this is it now if you're coming from
dotted 5 you're probably thinking wait a
second there was supposed to be a
startup.cs and I can configure services
and now I can so no you can you can
imagine that this is the configure
Services area so anything between here
you can register
and anything between the app and the app
run is actually your configure method
from the startup.cs the one where you
configure the middleware anything
between this
doesn't really need to be ordered unless
you materialize your dependencies
because they will be materialized on app
creation anything here however needs to
be ordered so if you use something like
Swagger and you want to have it outside
of authentication then you need to
register it before your
app.ad.netication call and so on
everything is in sequence here
and one of the big problems this can
cause if you're not careful is that you
can create as many apps as you want out
of that Builder because that Builder is
just instructions on how to make web app
so this would start to Applications so
be careful also if you try to
retroactively add the service
let's say a Singleton after you created
your app then this app won't be
retroactively updated with the service
the moment you create it it's there you
don't touch it
so let's go ahead and create our first
endpoint and I'm going to go with a very
simple
app dot map get
for hello world so hello
and I'm just going to say hello NDC
so let's go ahead and just run this
and I'm going to use this at dot HTTP
and file which has some predefined HTTP
requests
and I'm going to say run hello
so simple as that I have something that
returns effectively hello world hello
NDC
now let's make it a bit more complicated
because just returning raw text isn't
really fancy
so what we can say is hello object
and I can just simply return an
anonymous object here
and by default it will be serialized so
hello equals NDC
just
run this real quick
and
by default the Json generalizer is used
you get a response back now we can take
this a bit further because how often do
you just work with Anonymous objects you
don't really so I'm going to create a
record not that
here we go a user
and I'm going to have a full name so
string
full name
and I can very easily
scroll down say app.map get
user
and by just returning the object we have
full serialization let's do this make
chapsis
yeah you know what ciao us
fine
so let's rerun this
unfortunately hot reload doesn't work
for this because you can't retract
reload
register endpoints
so I have to stop and start every time
but again full serialization you get it
but
Nobody Does this nobody just has
endpoints without parameters now the
good thing is dotnet or minimal apis
support some special parameters to be
injected in the Lambda by default so I
can say map get
special
and I'm going to start with
I don't know the most basic one which is
the HTTP context so if you just say
context here by default
or not not my Nemesis parenthesis
here we go then I can just say
context dot response dot write a as Json
is saying and I can have the same user
copied over and then I have more control
over what I'm writing so if I also want
to specify things like the status code
the Response Code I can do that now for
this to work I have to turn this into an
async function
so this is a sync and this is awaited
one of the biggest problems this causes
is that you can technically return at
any point or you can technically not
have anything here
and nothing will start stop compiling
but this will not
you know it will fail only when you call
it it's very very dodgy the way this is
implemented which is why right as Json
async is not really used that much in
normal applications but in the same way
if you wanted to access things like the
request
query string parameters you have
everything here you have full access
but maybe you don't want that maybe you
want to narrow it down to some other
special parameters like HTTP request
or HTTP response
you can do that you can have HTTP
response here and only write that
you can also let's go back here
you can also have a cancellation token
so if you want to cancel your request
after some time you do that
and then you can pass that into your
async methods so you're not missing out
on anything by going down this route you
still have all the goodies of
controllers here or controlling actions
now
I want to show you how extra this can
get and I'm going to start with a get
request I'm going to say Extravaganza
here
and
I'm going to show you how we can inject
different parameters because minimal
apis and this sort of model structure
depends on a lot of implica and implied
or assumptions sorry
so if for example I say int age
where would this be coming from I didn't
specify where but if I say return new
age
then this has to come from somewhere so
if I just quickly run this it show you
it is going to be
the query string parameter by default
19. so you don't have to specify from
query by default any parameter on a get
request that is a primitive like this
will be mapped from the route you can
also be explicit about it so if you want
sorry from the query string if you want
it to be from the route then you can say
age and you can even have constraints
like end so if you do that then this
will come from the route
you can also go down a different path so
if I say here here
and then end
year here then age is query string year
is route
this can get very confusing because you
have all this cognitive load to keep in
mind you know this is coming from this
this is coming from this and it only
gets worse so
let's say that age actually comes from
from query string nope comes from query
string but it has a different name you
want it to be a in your query string we
can say from query
and then name equals
a
it turns out two equals doesn't work
here we go so if you do that then you
can map something like this where the
equation parameter is just an a you can
still call it whatever you want
internally
do you want the header
from header do you want to inject a
service
from your di container you can say from
service however
this is another thing if I just quickly
grab this date time provider
and I put it here
this isn't something magical by the way
it just is a way to test your daytime
while you're using it into your code you
just inject the interface and then you
can mock it if you need to
so if I just go here and I register this
here we go then I can just simply say
I date time provider
and I can use it
there we go
and even if I don't specify where they
should be coming from on Startup minimal
apis will actually detect that and say
oh this is coming from query this I can
map to Route this I don't know
but it's not a body because this is a
get I don't have a converter for it it
exists in dependency injection in a
container that's what it is and if you
do that then
you can see everything here
automatically mapped you still have
control to be explicit
and it goes even further if this was
actually a map post
then you can even have a user
coming from the body and you don't have
to specify anything so you can say
something like this
it can get too much
and that's why in dotnet 7
there was actually a new feature added
where you can say something like
um presentation request
and you can wrap all of that
into a record
so I can have everything here I'm not
going to rename anything just do not
waste any time but you can do this and
you can say as
parameters here
and you can pass down your object so
presentation request
request and then you can use it here so
if you want to access the age
you want to have everything in a single
contract you can which is a pretty neat
thing to do the problem is if I go down
that route I would be explicit about
where things are coming from just to
show you how this will fail if I don't
have the service in my di container but
I actually try to resolve it
then let's see what happens
so nothing fails on Startup the
application just started which
you know depending on who you ask isn't
really great because I'd like something
like this to be detected and startup but
if I do run it
response body is empty because in the
Run
you can see I got this error saying hey
age is coming from an attribute route
and body inferred
request is as parameter but the user is
unknown and there's a bit of a clash
with a provider here so it assumed that
the provider came from the body and the
user came from nowhere
so I'd be explicit you're gonna you're
gonna write safer code by doing this but
fundamentally
this is what it is about now there's
more features that we're adding.7 and
we're going to talk about them but
here we are
so
let's continue from here
there are actually a few unsupported
features or at least upon release there
are quite a few first there was no
support for MVC filters so if you have
any iasync action filters or result
filters or exception filters there was
none of that when it launched and you
still technically can't use those
there was no API version now not the
concept of API versioning you can still
if you want have V1 V2 V3 folders and
you can use route versioning or whatever
you choose to do maybe header but there
was a nuget package that Microsoft has
in the dot net organization that at the
time did not support minimal apis also
there was and there still isn't no
built-in support for validation so if
you want to validate an incoming object
you actually have to write your own
validator which in my case that is fine
because what I always did is I wrote my
own fluent validation sort of class and
I passed that through a custom
middleware so
I could still work my way around the
problem is there wasn't any filters
there so I had to do it every single
time for every endpoint
if I want to be fast
and there's also no support for all data
how many of you use old data
how many of you like it
yeah I thought so
there's no support for that but there it
might be coming mainly because Microsoft
themselves use our data and that might
be added in the future but it's not here
now in dotnet 7 we actually did get
filters in a new implementation it is
not the same type of filters but they're
very nice and they can be endpoint
specific very very nice clean
implementation and also the API version
you get package now supports that so if
you want to go and plug that in you can
do that and I do have a video on my
YouTube channel on how to do that
now validation still does not exist
built in however Microsoft is thinking
of ways to add it the problem is it
needs to be very unopinionated and
generic and also very very fast so
they're thinking Source generators and
from what I hear from David Fowler he
said it is so hacky you're gonna love it
so I don't know what that means let's
say and the last thing is you know for
the old data you might get it eventually
it's not here but to be honest consider
using a graphql with hot chocolate
I think it's a better experience if you
can
now
I want to go to a very interesting
phenomenon called
program.cs hell
so this was very much a common sentiment
when the minimal API has launched which
is this idea of oh donus 6 is out I'm
going to give it a go I'm going to try
to run a minimal API build one and then
they end up with six app.map get methods
and six classes in one program.cs they
hate themselves they think just you know
web API is better we're going backwards
and that is a very interesting
observation to me because
often do you make a controller when you
make a web API and then in that
controller you add let's say the domain
you're working with is a customer you
want your customer service your customer
contracts your customer repositories
your customer mediator handlers
validation you don't add all that in a
single controllers class you split it
nothing changes here minimal apis are
not one file apis all they are is a
strip down version of everything you
could do before and broken down to its
bare minimum
so let's talk about what minimal apis
are not explicitly so like we said not
one file API is just forget about it
when someone says that just correct them
minimal is about minimizing first the
cognitive load in getting started and
the entry level enabling anti-level
developers to build basically any API
they want
also that they're not just for demos as
you just saw however they're fantastic
for demos because I can very easily just
have everything in a single page scroll
up and down and you don't have to worry
about oh this is in this file and this
in this file and this in this file and
you know everything is there everything
is easy to do the problem with this is
that Microsoft also heavily use them for
demos and Microsoft demos are like 2000
lines of code and people say that and
think that's how you build an API it is
not how you build an API so don't do
that
and in the same way that they're not
just for demos they're not just for
beginners they are great for beginners
but in the hands of someone who really
can't structure a project they can get
really creative so I think maybe the
middle level is who it is really not for
or maybe not for but beginners and
experts
Prime candidates for this
and then the last thing is because I
hear this quite a bit actually then I'm
going to kill controllers the reason why
this came about quite a few times is
because Microsoft has been very vocal
about saying we expect 40 to 80 percent
of all new use cases to use minimal apis
which is a bit optimistic in my opinion
like it's not really gonna happen
um but certainly for some use cases it's
going to be very very good
very very viable as well
but at this point I actually want to
take a second to just address the
elephant in the room because
I do believe that controllers are
building apis are a really weird concept
and I I did not get it so I went back to
see why we're using controllers for for
building apis you know how do you think
they came about do you think that the 10
smartest people in Microsoft sat down
and said okay let's put it down
performance engineering architecture
structure
what's the best way to build an API and
they said oh yeah control this is the
way to do it
no what happened is they needed to ride
the whole rest API web API to wave
and they had this thing called MVC
so what if we take the controller aspect
which has validation model binding and
Json XML and HTML response and just keep
the C because really what is the last
time you used a view in your apis you
haven't so what are using controllers
which is an MVC construct in your apis
well it's just rebranded MVC
also models in NBC they're not really
API contracts and the way you we use
them because in API contracts and apis
in general you have an input and an
output object and they're separate
they're not the same thing
so
it's not quite models so we're using
just the C from MVC
and the truth is it was just the easiest
way to get it out of the door and have
it in the hands of consumers in a
reliable way because MVC did work and it
still works people still use it with
success there's nothing wrong with NPC
however I have an issue with that
structure because they have all these
methods these actions within that
controller that they never call each
other and the only thing that really
calls them is the router so you have a
bunch of public methods in a public
class that nothing explicitly calls
it doesn't really make sense why they
should be together and this becomes more
obvious if you think that really they're
actually violating the Open Class
principle
because what you do to add the new
endpoint into your API
you open that controllers class and you
edit it what do you do to remove one you
open that one the controls class and you
delete the method
so why are we doing that what's the
separation of concerns what are the same
responsibility oh my responsibilities is
a controller well why didn't you go more
now and have full control into that
responsibility
because it is not uncommon to have
Services injected on the controller
level that are only used on a single
action
but because those Services could be
transient or scoped Independence
injection those objects are being
instantiated every single time and
you're wasting memory for things that
will never be used by that service or by
that action so why are they sharing real
estate I really do not understand this
another thing is that they never share
State between actions because
controllers are actually scoped per
request so you don't have something that
will be reused by all the methods so why
are they all together just sounds very
dumb in isolation it sounds smart in the
context of MVC because you have a direct
correlation between your view calling
the controller but between the API
calling the controller there is no
correlation
and also when you have private methods
because you thought I'm gonna just
extract this private method I'm gonna
because it's getting too big and I'm
going to give it a nice name and use it
they usually used just by a single
action so you have a private method in a
class that's only used by a single
action
okay then should it be a local function
oh that looks too big in a single method
and then maybe you don't even need that
well why don't you just split that
then they do invoke middleware and
filters that you might not need
implicitly all that validation all that
model binding there's tons of things
behind the scenes that's happening that
your actions don't need but you're
paying the price of those objects being
instantiated and that memory needing to
be Gap is collected every single time
they have tried to make it efficient but
there's so much you can rip out of a
system like MVC that has been running
for years
now they can also grow to that thing
called fat controllers I don't know how
many of you have heard of this term but
they can grow to quite a lot a big size
and very commonly the the way the way
people solve this problem is they
actually introduce mediator and then
they move all the logic into a Handler
so they brag that okay my controlum
actions is actually just request mapping
mediator send and response mapping well
that sounds something like you can put
somewhere else and not have the
controller in the first place like why
do you need this if it's so simple
um and the truth is that the reason why
we have just accepted it and use it is
because the only viable option for
building apis in.net or they were the
only viable option if you really want to
be a nice rest API yes Nancy effects was
a thing but at the time people were not
really happy to base their whole
livelihood on the whole company on an
open source project that might die and
in fact it did eventually die now it is
sort of reincarnated with a different
project called Carter but I still
wouldn't use that because it's competing
with minimal apis and you're just
playing catch up
so let's talk about what this talk is
yeah let's talk about what this talk is
about really
and like with everything in life this
talk is about Lego it is always about
Lego and I promise you this metaphor
will make sense
so what do you see here just think
in your mind yes it is a Lego
Castle
but just try to think outside of the box
so what you have here is I have started
or have finished castle and I can see a
door I can see Foundation I can see
Windows there's a structure there is
another one over there and the great
thing about a half started or finished
structured is that if I go to my nephew
who is five and obviously five-year-old
not the smartest and I say build the
castle well here's watch Harry Potter
so he's gonna build something like this
without any experience just because
there is enough structure in something
like this to eventually lead to that now
it might not look that great because
like I said he's five but
it is good enough
but the good thing about this is that if
you give it to me who has never really
built any fancy customers but I do have
the imagination to use Lego
then I'm also sort of set in a path of
success because there's enough here for
me to get inspired and finish what
someone else has started
now here's what's very interesting to me
let's say that you take all of that away
and you give to the same five-year-old
ground
and a bucket of infinite amount of Lego
bricks with any color and any size
and I say hey build a castle
what he's probably gonna build will look
something like this now is this a castle
it depends on who you asked to me it
looks really bad
to him it does look like a castle that's
what he wanted to build it serves the
purpose he got a cracker that he used
his imagination and he built it
but then if I go to his mum who's
actually an architectural major medieval
architecture and Gothic architecture and
say hey can you build a castle with
those same ingredients
then what she's going to end up with is
potentially a masterpiece
do you get it
this is what controllers look like to me
there is enough structure you start from
this controller class from this from
this action
that there is no room for
experimentation in order for experiment
no room for experimentation means very
low likelihood of failure you're gonna
end up with something that on something
that is quite good not perfect but good
and that's why we have things like clean
architecture be so big because
experimentation actually starts past the
controller we sort of agree that
controller is a problem we need to solve
and then we add 15 layers of
abstractions because we're obsessed with
it just to complicate life and say oh if
in the future I need to change my
database layer how many of you have
changed your database service in your
project ever just show me how many of
you during that process didn't have to
change the interface that you abstracted
your thing around
yeah exactly one person
like if you go from something like an
rdbms to a nosql database your access
buttons will change
you won't be able to do the same things
that you did before so This Promise of
in case I change it is
a bad healthy diet in my opinion
but the good thing is Junior developers
meet developers and Senior developers
will end up with something that is
pretty good
but in the same way that a junior
developer will be the very bad API at
least the barrier of Entry was pretty
low you don't have to even worry about
something like this okay where do I put
the brick I have to find the right brick
to put the thing and then it's like even
that makes things complicated
but such an approach to a junior
developer with no experience makes it
very easy to get your foot through the
door and say you know what this thing
Returns what I need this thing can work
and here's the good thing about this
yes they built something bad but next
time they do it they're going to try to
do it better and better and better and
better and as the time goes on they're
going to improve and also the way to get
started was very easy there was nothing
you need to know about go crazy but take
a staff engineer a principal engineer or
a senior engineer too whatever we call
them these days
and we say Okay create a properly very
nicely architected API with all the
tools you can ever need then they will
certainly build something like this
because now they have the freedom to do
that and the freedom to control their
Foundation you cannot build something
like this
on this Foundation it's just impossible
you're going to build basically a castle
on top of a toothpick
which is in my opinion what clean
architecture is
so what are minimal apis really well
again in my opinion
I think they're in an opinion the way
with high performance apis inductment
with minimal amount of implicitly added
features and the flexibility to opt in
the features and the structure that you
need is about you is about choice
so now with all that said let's take a
look at what is possible with minimal
apis
when I go back to this project over here
I'm going to show you this abstraction
API now this is on GitHub so if you
wanna
use it and do something with it
just says Nick shops is GitHub you're
going to find it under a minimal API
so what do I have here this is an API
built on minimal API technology
you wouldn't know just by looking at it
because it has folders it has settings
it has validation it has structure well
this is only possible because we now
have minimal API technology backing it
up there are no controllers in here I'm
gonna start this
and show you how it works
so your regular apis here
and then I'm going to go
to the structure.http and call some
endpoints so what I can do this is a
rest API with customers being the object
you're dealing with
and I'm gonna go and try to get all the
customers in the system now there is no
customers so I'm going to get an empty
response
what I can do is I can create a customer
so I'm going to go here and just say
create that customer and the customer
was created I used update to do that
or did I
no I just create that's good so you have
201 created the right status code you
have the location header over here this
is exactly how rest API would be I can
go ahead and edit that user using the ID
and delete that user
excuse me and you can also retrieve that
user so this works and behaves as a rest
API
um it also if I go in the console
has full Swagger support
so
all my documentation about this API is
here customers endpoint the object is
here that accepts is here everything is
here
very very nicely the request did not
pass validation checks customer was
created successfully this is all the
documentation you need in your minimal
API
how is that even possible
let's take a look how it is my entry
point for this structure is actually
these endpoints folder so I have all of
my endpoints for my customer in here so
if I want to create a customer all I do
is I say httpost customer and then in
this case I say allow Anonymous I have
no Authentication
and then I create a class
that extends the class endpoint and then
I specify my input and my output my
request contract and my response
contract
and that is it I don't have to
explicitly
make it be referenced anywhere because
in program.cs it will be automatically
grabbed so all I need to do is actually
create a class extend endpoint and that
is it I have an endpoint and now in here
I have everything that is just
explicitly required by this endpoint and
nothing else customer service that is it
do I need a logger it's only injected
here do I need something specific to
create like publish a message for
customer creation only here I don't need
to inject for that anywhere else like
they get which is what you would do in
controllers
and then I have this handle async method
where I'm getting the request I do have
the cancellation token I'm converting it
to a customer and then create map return
and that is it that's all create does I
can go to other things like get all same
story in this case endpoint without
request because get all doesn't have an
object that you need to get it's just a
customer's call
same thing you return it and please buy
do not think that this is the way you
should be building an API this is just
one of the ways you can build them just
because now it is truly possible yes
technically you can say Nick you could
do that by having single action
controllers you didn't need this but
this is actually way faster because
minimal apis are faster and now you
control the full pipeline which you do
not do in Old School MVC
another thing is that now if I want to
have a validator the only thing I need
to do is just create the validator class
using fluent validation
and then specify the request object
and that is it nor do I need to say this
validates this it is implied based on
what the abstract validator is created
for
so if it's not empty it's gonna fail or
if it is empty it's gonna fail
same with everything else the other
thing is the summaries if I want to
document an endpoint the only thing I
need to say is create a summary class
that extends summary and wraps that
endpoint so summary for that endpoint
and all of my documentation for that
endpoint is here you could of course use
XML commands as well on the 10 point
class that's totally fine but you can
also have it in a single class with
which I personally prefer
and then you have other stuff like your
mapping if you want to have any of that
and the startup.cs which is where all
the magic is happening so that's what my
startup.cs is my project.cs looks like
sorry program
and the only thing I have here is this
add fast end points call now fasting
points is a third part library that is
using minimal ABS to make that possible
I was actually working on something that
is effectively What fast and points and
end up being and because the developer
was way faster than me I actually just
reused that so fast and points is what
provides all this logic
and then we have a middleware to catch
everything like I said sequence does
matter and then I'm not cheating here
the only thing I'm hiding from you is
this error response building so if we
catch a failure we wrap it into a
specific object and then we'll just
retire it
but really that is it
so
maybe it is not for you
but it is definitely for me and what I
needed and this is again what is this is
about it's about you it's about choice
now let's talk about the phenomenon now
I like to call minimal Valley just to
sort of describe what's the minimal API
viability per project and even though
the horizontal line is supposed to show
time
um it's really type of project because
the life cycle of a product usually
these days looks like this
so I think that minimal API is extremely
viable for beginner projects demos like
we already saw proof of Concepts and
will actually approve Concepts
so for those things you can just very
really get started you can very quickly
have a demo very quickly have a proof of
concept and the amazing thing about the
last one is that you can take your POC
exactly as it is and turn it into aerial
application without too much effort
because you have a blazing fast
structure with minimal apis you can just
reuse that you don't need to migrate or
graduate into controllers which is the
Assumption of many people
but I don't think that it's really
viable for this chunky Enterprise
applications now chunky Enterprise
applications doesn't really mean you
know monoliths Beyond saving it can
still be a very well architected and
modular monolith
but I don't think that the type of
project company and developer really
will benefit from moving away because if
your API or your app is slow you're not
gonna you're not going to get anything
from the benefits of using window apis
however I do think that the best case
scenario for minimal EPS in the best use
case is actually microservices minimal
API micro Services both of them are
supposed to be small I've never written
one that's more than 1.5
000 lines of code
the complexities on the architecture so
why don't we keep the code very very
simple and easy to work with
so that's how I feel about this now
I want to wrap this talk by talking
about the importance of minimal apis
about.net in general and about you
let's talk about how people get into a
programming language
so there's many ways and this is not an
exhaustive list but they probably have
an idea they want to build
that's how many of you maybe got started
um my cousin wanted to get started with
programming because he wanted to build
Tetris from scratch how do you do that
well I have an idea I'm gonna just do it
University School College I'm sure many
of you have also started program because
of that
curiosity as a beginner how do you do
that or that person on YouTube said they
can make I don't know 150 000 dollars a
year by just taking a bootcamp I want to
do that as well that's a lie by the way
it's never going to happen
well you know they're selling the dream
also curiosity is an experienced
programmer this is another one I
personally really like to get into other
programming languages to see where
c-sharp is actually getting inspired
from because it's just all of these
features being added they're not
features you've never seen anywhere else
they're all coming from somewhere
usually a shop
and the last thing is because the
company is using it that's how I got
started with C sharp I desperately in
the job the first person who said yes
um just happened to use C sharp in the
company and I just got into it
but here's the thing
these are the only ones that really are
relevant for c-sharp now you can say
Nick the unity game engine actually gets
a ton of people into c-sharp but the
truth is for any of you who have seen
Unity code
it's a whole different story it's the
wild west over there there's no rules in
the way you can write C sharp in unity
so it's not the type of developer that
would really graduate into an aspen core
developer and maybe it's not developer
you really want to hire so let's focus
on these three
so here's the thing about this
only this one is one that we can sort of
control with c-sharp because
universities change what they teach
schools or colleges and companies
migrate from java to node to ABC shop to
rust eventually to whatever they want
so let's take that keep that in mind and
take that and talk about cranes and you
know how the Lego thing actually worked
this one won't this is just completely
random
it's not gonna happen
so how do trainers work so you get on
the train
you stay on the train you get off the
train and the trainer will keep doing
this journey as long as there's
passengers
and this very much applies to many
things in life as well as in programming
languages
so let's talk about the programming
language Express
people pick up a language
people use a language people stop using
a language and the language is dying
when a plus B minus C is decreasing over
time
so effectively the more people the less
people you have using a language over
time that's when your language is dying
but
there's also a catch-22 with this
situation because the more people use
the language the more people are likely
to use a language and the more people
stop using a language then more people
will stop using a language because it's
not popular anymore
so if you get into that downhill Trend
it's very hard to recover
c-sharp is good at B and C at people
using the language they love it I
absolutely love it and I've written many
languages since I got started with C
sharp and always something is missing
and also people stop using C sharp
because it's been around for 20 years
maybe you picked it up at your 40s
you're retired now you don't need to use
it anymore so with constant amount of
people you know retiring or stop using
it we also need an equal amount of
people picking it up if we want the
people the language to to survive
so ultimately minimal apis are a step
towards increasing a it is a step
towards getting it to the hands of new
Developers
that are the developers that will
eventually be the future of.net
so
when you hear people say things or you
say things like they've done the thing
should not be working on things like
this this is not something that they
should be wasting the time with this is
not for me well the truth is that if you
want to be in a situation where you can
hire the next generation of C sharp and
Doctor Developers
then it is for you even if it's not for
you
thank you very much and keep coding
foreign